and the funny things when I get getting
famous I just don't know why I had to
keep doing a dangerous stunt because
other fans
they liked it and later on it's not for
the fans anymore for myself I want to
challenge myself and even today I
challenge myself I just
yes I'm not young anymore but I still
want to do the young person things John
then after I get hurt okay I'm Oh be
careful
jump lower not too high but I still like
to do my own stunts
why because you really under C it what
SIA tell you look at Wow myself how can
you tell tell my son no father's you
know that's a double but now I today
look at my old film Wow later on you
look at the Super Cup every shot that's
me yeah but a lot of people people ask
me to use scare I do scare honestly
every stunt I'm really really scared
like the later on you see on the in the
in the Super Cup that's just that's a
shock from the building jump to the
helicopter that shot really really
scared
oh yeah it's really that was ridiculous
really ridiculous you know when the
problem is when we design that's done
for okay next year we do a movie okay
let's sit down they talk about oh we
have idea to jump down helicopter all
cuckoo cuckoo now but by the time coming
boom boom boom boom
and I remember the first day because we
have to tell the government people what
we're doing and the government people
have to in Malaysia really thank you
Malaysia government they they blocked
the whole downtown last to do these kind
of things and the helicopter come then
before I try oh hello Kara comes in
Indian Indian and the first day they
come I said not because too close
because that's the building that's the
building the helicopter was here go away
yeah almost
then tomorrow tomorrow then I'm honestly
I'm really scared when you look down
they put a Apple box the Apple box is
like tofu that's more and also also you
you know when I get hurt in the
Yugoslavia because it's a jump so this
why I always scare about young the
Yugoslavia because I jump I swing and
the tree break I drop so when I do a
Super Cup yeah I'm thinking these kind
of things just the stunts proud the stun
difficult studies jump you have less
somebody something stopped you otherwise
you swing after we swing if I my hair
let go then I would go to the street
even the street there's a catch
dude they cannot block the street so
they blocked their garden they put the I
said no the car when you jump you you
directly go to the street so I always
see the street at room shown then I tell
when I should that moment can you block
the street at least I for myself not die
and car keep going on
so this is okay okay okay then second
the second day the second day we're
doing something they tell and suddenly
one of the the producer tell me Jackie
look across the street and I look at the
cross the street Wow all press paparazzi
with all the long legs everybody waiting
I said I I got a job today
otherwise they they would write
something and what can what can I do
okay let's do it you know just like it's
like what no when I doing this kind of
stunt is really like a hugging yanggeum
gone execution really it's like a public
execution yeah
I notice you see all the people
downstairs you order you see all the
cameramen get ready you see all a camera
get ready Chet and the roof just by
yourself and you have to sit there might
your heart just keep boom I had to
pretend I know that it's some of the
camera watching me that just then I then
I always watch that watch then huh
then I you have to count the step know 1
2 3 4 then you have to turn because at
that time you know that the jump ok then
I go to the the parking helicopter
parking then I put the ladder
ok I think probably like this 1 2 3 4
the number 3 how do you say the bar the
bar and I put the wrap things on the bar
and make sure everything is tight ok
then I go back to the roof then I say
ready then they call high like a calm
way they have to in some other place
about 15 minutes come to there then 15
minutes you can get to know me and the
people around me with all of walkie
talkie
okay hello camera ok block the road the
row below the Rosa blah I come then you
see the Helicarrier come helicopter he
cannot he he just don't know it's not
like packing he was on the top he don't
know he just watch me - why he's just
about the I said - - I come come come
- close he's just too difficult to to
balance you just at the end I just I
just okay
I think almost Oh what the hell me
really this is I said Oh what the hell I
just one two three I see the Red Dog I
jump you know what happened I don't know
that's the ring you know the helicopter
the wing rotor you chum you who your
whole body just drop then I see the red
dot I catch the last - Wow catch last -
boom I catch until a helicopter
let me down to the roof another
helicopter go away then I chop dinner oh
I I watch downstairs it's not what you
go there and let the cameraman shoot me